[Music]
thank you this is the debate matter in
mind I'm Jonah Cavanaugh and the basic
premise of the debate is that
neuroscience has enabled us to posit
theories about how the brain affects the
body but there's still no prevailing
theory to explain how the matter of the
brain affects or creates even thought
and experience so the key question
within the debates is is consciousness
inexplicable at present because it is
not part of the material world or is it
somehow physical and within the grasp of
those scientists who are trying to track
it and trace it or indeed if these
notions of the material versus the
immaterial or mind versus matter are
obsolete to need to be revised and here
to discuss this we have a very
distinguished panel I shall introduce
Marcus first Marcus Gabriel is
philosopher and author of transcendental
ontology and also why the world does not
exist and he's director at the
International Centre for philosophy at
Bonn he's Germany's youngest ever chair
in philosophy and he teaches philosophy
in nine languages then we have ray
brassia here but I don't speak English
okay yes you know invented languages
don't count ray brassia is the
philosopher at the American University
of Beirut and he's also of nil
unbound he's also translated works by
Alain Badiou
and Quentin mayor sue and he's one of
the pioneers of speculative realism and
I'm sure he'll explain if you would like
what that is and Ava yeah Blanca here at
the end is professor of history and
philosophy of science at Tel Aviv she's
a theoretical biologist her books
include evolution in four dimensions
which she wrote with Mary and lamb and
she's best known for her work in
epigenetic inheritance so the format of
the debates is that the speakers have
four minutes only to answer a question I
shall pose them shortly then we'll have
a theme debate in three rough parts and
then I'll turn it over to you the
audience so the opening question which
I'll turn
two markers first for an answer is is
consciousness inexplicable because it is
not part of the material world thanks
Marcus
so I think that the
question-how mind fits into nature or
how mine for latest Oh meta in the way
that we are used to asking it right now
is completely ill-posed on on many
different fronts so let me begin you
know for saying something about you know
the book tight why the world does not
exist what I'm denying is the
metaphysical principle of the unity of
reality so for one thing I believe it's
philosophically misguided to believe
that there's one big entity or domain
the world and that we have to fit
everything into that domain which would
be defined for instance as the absolute
totality of everything which exists and
then you could start debating about you
know what really exists this mind really
existed this matter really exists etc if
that's the way of approaching the topic
then you already misguided because you
make way too many metaphysical
assumptions that I think are ultimately
untenable so first of all I think we
have to overcome metaphysics and
therefore also questions such as you
know should we be dualist that is what
we believe that there two kinds of
substances should we be monist that is
belief that there's just one substance
should we be pluralist that is belief
that there are whatever many substances
okay so I think the early modern debates
that are still with us and that have
posed the problem of consciousness the
way that we're still discussing it I
think those debates are as misguided as
early modern physics so all of this is
misguided we need a new framework in
order to ask the question nevertheless
there are versions of the question that
are with us that are tenable but you
have to rephrase the premises of the
debate or so I believe so let's look for
instance at the at notions like mind and
consciousness and self consciousness etc
what's remarkable if you come from a
different you know like non-english
speaking community such as a
german-speaking community is how
surprising it is you know like we have
no German word for what in English is
called mind you cannot translate mind
into English as much as you cannot
translate the German word Geist into
English okay they are not exact cinnamon
so I have a hard time even understanding
what people mean when they ask you know
mind that matter you know mind for me is
like shhhhh mind you know so you have to
give me you have to give it meaning and
when I look at you know the meaning that
people are trying to give it you know
then philosophers at least will tell you
something like you know if you want to
know what - you got to find the mark of
the mental what's the mark
the mental well the mark of the mental
is what makes something mental
instead of non mental well that's of
course not very helpful because mental
is just Latin for mine so that doesn't
really get us anywhere so what they then
say and that is still the most hopeful
way of even making sense of the question
I think is they say something like yeah
forget about mine let's talk about
consciousness and then things get really
tricky because I think that
consciousness might also mean all sorts
of things some things that we call
consciousness I think are of course
biological phenomena such as being awake
you know the fact that I'm awake right
now and not you know so drunk that I
can't even engage in a debate well those
facts I'm not on LSD I'm for all I know
you know like those facts are biological
obviously so there's no I don't think
there's a mind matter problem there
first of all we can explain them etc so
I don't believe that there's what people
have called the heart problem I don't
think that there you know you can look
at my brain and then it looks stupid and
just pink and but from within you know
I'm awake so how do days they relate to
each other well here's how they relate
to each other you know if your brain is
a certain state in a certain state then
you are awake so that depth that's I
think it's not a problem but there are
problems with consciousness such as you
know like how can I ever be in a truth
app state I think that's an interesting
question so how can brains have access
to truth up States even though brains
you know do not seem particularly suited
to you know due to their evolutionary
origin etc - grasping you know as it
were pure truth such as two plus two
equals four etc so how is it possible
that brains you know realize states that
make it possible for us to significantly
go beyond anything that takes place
within our heads so you know to throw
out another credo you know the external
is credo but a little bit more
generalized I think that you know parts
of consciousness just ain't in the head
so if you're looking for consciousness
you know within your skull then you will
find some elements of what we
legitimately call consciousness and they
are not mysterious but you will also
find you know other features that we
ascribe to consciousness such as you
know those features that put us in
contact with something outside or a
skull so for me the real interesting
question is
how is it possible for you know
organisms to grasp propositions I think
that's an interesting question that
comes with all sorts of riddles
but the riddles are quite different from
those that you know the metaphysical
framework is allowed to post within
which we are currently operating I think
that framework is profoundly confused
well my answers
would be straightforwardly no and I
think that there's the terms I also I
agree with much of what Marcus said that
the the question is badly posed or badly
frames that there's a fundamental
confusion which underlies the premises
of the question I think the fundamental
distinction to get going on this problem
is is between understand the difference
between knowing what we mean when we use
the word consciousness and knowing what
consciousness is there's a fundamental
difference between knowing what
something means and knowing what
something is we human beings knew what
water meant long before they understood
what water truly is it's micro physical
structure the presumption that we are
better acquainted with their own minds
than anything else which is for instance
the fundamental Cartesian assumption is
I think you're predicated on this
confusion there's this assumption that
we are directly acquainted with the
constitutive properties of our own
mental states or conscious experiences
and that this somehow this our
familiarity with our own minds means
that we're in a position to say what
they are and what distinguishes them
from other any other natural phenomenon
the arguments there's been a revival of
dualism in recent anglo-american
philosophy the arguments for dualism
such as the famous explanatory gap
argument was formulated by David
Chalmers in 1996 in his conscious mind
it seems to me that they all proceeds
from the assumption in terms of this
conflation between knowing what
something means and knowing what
something is
Chalmers begins with the premise that we
are directly acquainted with the so
called phenomenal properties of our
conscious States and then concludes that
these properties which are intrinsic
qualities of our experience
or fundamentally different in kind from
the types of properties catalogued by
physical science that is physical
science can tell us about the functional
or relational properties of entities but
never about their intrinsic or non
relational features
[Music]